film films they're an exciting time in
our lives hiding you know if you want to
be a part of it there's this place that
we've talked about before in case you're
new it's called Full Sail Full Sail
University University John yeah can you
start telling them a little bit about
what that is I may be all like interject
working in the film industry is an
exciting opportunity and a rewarding
experience you might not know how to get
involved or even what you would want to
do you just know that you want to make a
movie well Full Sail can help you with
that they offer degrees on campus and on
the Internet otherwise known as online
that can really show you what it's like
to we're gonna film from start to finish
you even get a work hands-on with the
same equipment the professionals use the
best way to learn experience they have a
campus undergraduate program that
basically gives you access to and an
overview of pretty much every part of
the process so if you don't know which
what you want to do you can have
experience behind the camera with
editing with writing with directing you
know you can really find your niche also
check out the online digital
cinematography degree where you can
learn online basics with a cinematic
digital spin Full Sail grads have worked
on all kinds of big and recognizable
movies avengers age of ultron jurassic
world frozen to name a few i think they
worked on minions as well if you want to
find out more about these film programs
and how to get started visit the link in
the description box otherwise known as
beat i.t period ly / capital F s dashes
to lock apps to the PAP LM it's an
abbreviated think it's an abbreviation
uh know what I'm saying matters yeah
because it'll probably rear out you to
like Full Sail calm / blah blah blah
really thats do yeah it's an abbreviated
look so shouldn't we like actually find
out the real link for these people learn
dot Full Sail die edu / Full Sail slice
so much code yet wow that's a lot to
remember just just put your I have to
say all that you don't so
least 150 words make sure i have to say
on i don't have to sail alright i guess
i'm not gonna say it but that's my
choice visit them guys i'm sure you all
know about a thing called the Cinematic
Universe there's a lot of cinematic
universes that are being formed these
days people yeah it's a little too much
in my opinion it's like people saw that
Marvel was doing it well then everyone
was like well how do we do this out of
luck everything anytime somebody does
something that really works and makes
money everyone's like we also have to do
that now yeah like DC doing that not a
complaint because I'm like well yeah
it's a comic book you know universe
movie same kind of theory yeah exactly
so that totally makes sense but then
you're here I'm hearing like these other
kinds which I guess are not totally
different because they got the classic
horror movies now rebooting the mummy
they're rebooting the Wolfman the RIBA
and they want them all to be connected
and I guess they kind of did that with
like the original black and white film
sort of i don't think that was their
intention back then no I mean this seems
like they're like we got to make sure
these off they were thinking Universal
Monsters and sometimes I met Abbott and
Costello the Cinematic Universe now is
like you're always aware of the
connections between the different movies
yeah it's always about crossover and I
don't feel like those old movies did
that as much they're gonna cross over
the 21 Jump Street with the new men in
black I can see that working honestly
because then the men in black movie will
feel like a spin-off of that movie I'm
only really excited about that because
it's so strange i'm like yeah if you're
gonna use this for something that sounds
weird on paper i'm always happy when
somebody does that it's not the same
thing as all of these you know what I'm
really regretting what I came in here to
talk about my problems with it on
finding is me getting excited for these
movies as I'm talking about it's pretty
cool actually I don't out of it I think
it's cool when they use it the right way
and some of these Cinematic Universe is
sound cool and some of them I'm like why
do you just I guess the worrisome thing
is when I feel like it's thrown in your
face when like Iron Man 2 did it like
that was everyone's big you know
rebuttal with iron man two was that it
was really
late look at the Avengers we're gonna
we're gonna be there like Batman V
Superman does it tell ya that me super
Mike they wanted releases Ram these
crossovers in here like I didn't need
this in this movie the x-men Cinematic
Universe is separate from the MCU
whether the x-men Cinematic Universe you
know you got like you got Deadpool and
you had the x-men first class you got
your own Wolverine movies now I like it
when they do that when they use it as a
storytelling tool I think it's cool when
they use it just just to remind you that
other movies exist it gets a little
frustrating to me I feel like Easter
eggs aren't as fun as they used to be
because now on easter egg is like oh
that's probably gonna lead to another
french yeah you see the problem with
these Cinematic Universe is now though
there's something that seems on organic
or unnecessary to the point where it's
like they're just trying to catch it's
like when you do a sequel that doesn't
need to be done or like a remake that
doesn't need to be done like the Star
Wars Cinematic Universe I think is a
good idea this is what I mean now I'm
loving it again well stars to have
universe i think is cool because it's a
galaxy now yolks were so many different
people it's not unheard of for that
series in general break outside of
movies like there are sorrows books and
video games and comics and there's so
much lore and so many different things
to pick apart it's not just the moon and
it was the biggest prequels of all time
Star Wars lends itself because it is a
universe with multiple planets and
political situations wars and stuff like
you can do a lot there I feel like if
the project lends itself i'm happy i
just get weary when every week there's a
new cinematic universe we're gonna have
to have like this hasbro need one well
think about a man GI joe and
transformers coming together imagine if
they have mark wahlberg and dwayne
johnson in a transformers movie together
I haven't even thought about that soul
right now this very well sound that felt
like because I've already really talking
about the Transformers trailers always
look fun and then I ever want to see I'm
like it's aa you know what just honestly
kind of takes me off about the whole
Cinematic Universe thing is it's pretty
much what sparked it was [ __ ] batman
be superman was the titles of two of
like really low no okay marvel like
annoy me at some point but i'm a V
Superman when they
it just asleep when they just were like
here here's a Justice League trailer for
you in the middle of the movie with
really no strong tires oh oh that yeah
like that I was when I was lying
strating that's when I got really
annoyed with this whole idea but but
there's a campaign for Batman V Superman
seem like they didn't care about that
movie and they wanted to get right to
Justice League there's the kaiju
cinematic universe now where they're
gonna take Godzilla they're rebooting
the King Kong world and then King Kong
ain't God so they're gonna verse each
other hey man we've been wanting that
for a long time I don't care how cheesy
and [ __ ] stupid it sounds and how
kind of ruins here a lot Edwards is
Godzilla because his Godzilla was like
is a special Godzilla yeah no it's like
we're gonna francese and turn us into a
cinematic universe Lee know some people
don't like his Godzilla I really didn't
i'm bummed to not see that continue cuz
that was a chance to kind of do
something a little different and and now
they're taking it and turning it into
the thing that yeah so now it's gonna be
like Godzilla in your face most likely
yes yes ooh the stuff that meter yeah
exactly what I'm like hey Kong vs
Godzilla could be cool but I'd rather
just see them continue those stories he
sees okay like one unnecessary cinematic
universe like I guess could work but i
honestly think no one's really gonna
give a [ __ ] they're trying to make a
Robin Hood Cinematic Universe you do
movies of the other merry men oh I'm
like I don't think anyone's that
interest there's like a small chance
that could just be gangbusters and
everyone will love it and there will be
a Robin Hood research my initial
reaction to it is like who asks for that
this is the closest thing movies will
get to being as good as like how some
television shows get to be though
sometimes know about them listen you
haven't seen captain america civil war
hey I'm not saying it can't happen but
hold on Joe I don't think have you seen
captain america civil war that movie is
brilliant that's one movie out of a
cinematic universe that works what Herod
is it whoa impactful I'm this Oh impact
I'm not saying they won't huz it had
it's time to lead up to that true but I
don't think cinematic universes are the
key to that essence like fair point I
don't know so mad about
because you didn't see Captain America
so I want to go see Captain America's
award glenda screening I I was on a
plane that day I'm sorry there should be
some cinematic universes that they
should really go out of their way to
make the Godfather super well cuz I'm
wondering like are they gonna ever
change their genre or a cinematic
universe is going to always be you know
generally high concept action movies I
feel like if you're gonna franchise [ __ ]
might as well go with a cinematic
universe instead of just a bunch of
sequels there's a benefit to that I
guess yet cuz you can do spin off nice
man variety and PB mortimore because
that's what makes a television show work
for so long they like these great
[ __ ] TV shows nowadays because
sometimes movies don't have enough time
for character because they gotta deliver
plot and these big kind of [ __ ] films
they tend to sacrifice character a
little bit more for plot as opposed to
the shows like the daredevil show i love
Jessica Jones there's a lot of character
like a heavy amount of character I
almost feel like the budget range that
is disappearing from movies you know
like that sort of nice middle ground of
mid budget movies have just moved and
become television shows you don't have
necessarily the budget to make a movies
worth of a set piece every time but you
can put some great action and then you
have to fill that in with better
character development better stories and
also just you know you can because you
know you don't have to wrap this up in
three hours I don't know if that could
help movies or not I don't know if
movies are going to get better about
those things just because they have
cinematic universes it would be nice if
they did listen okay I know a great one
line this is a genuine one not a funny
one okay now some might say this already
is this I don't think so the Lord of the
Rings cinematic universe um Jonny G
maybe they're just part of middle-earth
if they're like the house oh no that's
what I mean okay Peter Jackson just goes
somewhere else George Lucas's himself
out of the situation you know what I
mean it's a delta or someone to just do
it separate movie in the world yeah this
have to be like Legolas the movie let's
do another movie that's what makes the
video games of some of these Lord of the
Rings based games so worthwhile is the
fact that I like huh the cool part of
the story to know that's kind of what
Star Wars is doing to with their older
films that's the tricky part and I don't
exactly
no what the magic key is like some of
these Cinematic Universe has come out
and they make sense and I'm like oh yeah
there are lots of different stories you
can tell and then some of them I'm like
what makes this story worth you know
tell him the friend Cinematic Universe
get all the original actors back for
friends and each one of them gets their
own movie and then they come together
for the seventh movie all the friends
come back the Nintendo Cinematic
Universe do okay this video started out
maybe I like in cinematic universe is I
want to get involved I'm your guy I'm
your guy I don't know i think it's it's
cool when it's in the right place isn't
it it doesn't need to be everything you
a bunch of different animated films you
bring them all together for like one of
them the super smash brothers movie the
mario party now they just be like morals
on that they could do something weird
like someone brought them into this one
universe together that magic hand from
super smash brothers that just attacks
you oh I'm still oh I'm still waiting
for that that's good but light and Elena
so do I know can you make a good movie
out of a fighting video game dude I
think you can make a great Tekken film
if someone took their time to actually
like look at the story for a second yeah
what does that happen with video game
movies so much they always come out they
have all these nothing just you wait one
once one video game movie gets it right
really I don't know how many video game
movie salad hell needs better dialogue
but I thought I got it mostly right
heard legendaries working on a real life
Pokemon movie I'm curious gotta catch em
all I feel like I'm so married to what
they look like his cartoons I don't know
how I would deal with real people but
that would be part I have I know I'm
auditioning for a brock i'm horny missy
editor I feel like Cinematic Universe I
want to play Gary you should I should be
here bi you smash uh-huh gonna go catch
more Pokemon my [ __ ] tonight yeah I
got Nurse Joy over here I'm cool I got a
backpack I got back back I'm going to
Viridian City yeah catch you on the
flipside gonna ride my bullets or
that's about as I strong my Bulbasaur
it's like a rat in the booth for a
minute there was franchises and now in
cinematic universes and I get a little
worried when people are only looking
into the future I just want everybody to
focus on the the movie at hand because
it's really easy to screw up a movie
trying to set up a cinematic universe
like you still have to find that magic
middle point where you're still caring
about each movie and not just
calculating I like it when Cinematic
Universe is form uniquely and
organically like Deadpool I felt really
worked in terms of the x-men universe
well yeah I feel like I want to get
imperative but didn't feel forced in
there and a lot of yes I mean people
cared about it and when they it
delivered it is unique it was different
it wasn't like any of the x-men films
well that was something that he took so
much convincing is like everyone had to
be like I don't know like it wasn't a
marketable idea and they found a way to
work yeah it's like one of the highest
grossing r-rated films of all time yeah
yeah it's like no I don't wanna say that
and of in terms of Cinematic Universe
movies that's 1 i've seen recently where
I was like thank you for acknowledging
what's you know kind of wrote about
these movies and doing something unique
just being yourself in doing something a
little new and commenting on the genre
and trying to expand it you know and I
feel like if people infuse these movies
with that kind of spirit that's sort of
like you know genuine loving care for
the value of the property then this
could be really cool I just don't think
that everything has to be a cinematic
universe as part of the magic of
Deadpool is that it came out of the side
you know because what's adaptable
Cinematic Universe how's that gonna play
into the rest of marble and the rest of
x-men because it doesn't exactly match
them you know it's like x-men can come
to dead bull became Deadpool go to X and
I can't do this I'm just saying but this
is a reasonable concern like no I told
her I was just caught from what I was
doing okay I'm sorry that's fun if
you're new to youtube this is called a
channel you don't want to set up an
account you don't want to set up an
account you know gmail is if you
probably after watching this you're
gonna be like I want to get notified
whenever these guys have a new video
don't eat it always and subscribe to the
real chicks John for some reason is
called reasons to Jerry and find out why
hopefully he'll take a chance ever known